j'avais alors donc en mal à 64 24 ans et
demi ça se déroule à quatre mamans et
les garçons des filles et trois petits
enfants
elles ont besoin d'alliés un patrimoine
via la taille et mais elle devient philo
qui fait pleurer plupart par mois et
encore le joyeux fous les trous dedans
c'est là quand j'aurais enfin flambé
méfaits commis tracé du vague et ravad
aucune matière à réfléchir à guipavas du
drôle et ça c'est mon papa t elle à 9 h
20 min nos petits montréalais grâce aux
sur son banc de l'histoire la religion &
carry il ya toujours foule a bondi
existe je viens là que soit il n'existe
pas de pain à voler par l'effet bettié
pour s'en sortir dans la misére ans la
maison les médias noient il faut
connaître pour vous pouvez me semble pas
y penser c'est un but qui n'altère pas
perdre les traditions la tradition là ou
bien on prend un but immédiat hebba
global et par des guêpes et coutumes
ce à quoi le soir aura plus rien de nous